c'est un anniversaire au goût amer que
commémore cette année les tunisiens
celui d'une révolution qui n'a pas tenu
ses promesses
dix ans après le bilan est contrasté
entre les petites victoires notamment
sur le plan des libertés individuelles
et de la démocratie et les grandes
déceptions qu'elles soient économiques
ou sociales
dans une tunisie à bout de souffle l'un
des plus grands obstacles demeurent la
crise politique qui mine les efforts de
changement bris de la croissance et rend
quasi impossible toute réforme
une instabilité politique fruit de
conflits partisans et d'absence de
consensus
en une décennie la tunisie a connu pas
moins de dix gouvernements et 365
ministres et secrétaires d'état au coeur
des critiques
le parti ennahda qui semble faire le jeu
des alliances et orienter la politique
de la jeune démocratie
pour l'opposition le parti islamiste ne
fait que reproduire les pratiques de
l'ancien pouvoir par sa mainmise sur les
secteurs clés du pays
si pour certains il est la cause du
désenchantement nationale ennahda pointe
du doigt le mode de scrutin à la
proportionnelle responsable selon lui de
l'instabilité politique du pays depuis
2013 le parti ennahda est arrivé au
pouvoir alors qu'il n'a jamais incarné
la révolution il est arrivé avec une
volonté de changement politique en
interne on a alors vu un conflit de
pouvoir entre le parti ennahdha et les
restes de l'ancien système pour aboutir
à une coalition fossé qui dessert les
intérêts des tunisiens ont demeurent
otages d'une trêve dominé par le parti
islamiste à l'origine de cette crise que
nous traversons aujourd'hui on ne peut
pas faire peser la responsabilité à un
seul parti politique c'est ce n'est pas
véridique ce n'est pas pertinent ni sur
le plan juridique ni sur le plan
politique après nous sommes condamnés à
chercher des consensus a assez de
dégager des poings d'antan des
dénominateurs communs
je pense qu'il existe mais il faut aller
au delà des tergiversations et des
contradictions purement idéologique et
aller au delà pour apporter des
solutions à propos de tunisiens quitte à
penser sérieusement à changer la loi
électorale
au delà des duels partisane et d'une
crise économique dont la tunisie
du mal à se relever à laquelle s'ajoute
la crise juqu'au vis des menaces
terroristes
omniprésente les fondements mêmes du
système politique tunisien de son mode
de scrutin peuvent expliquer la
léthargie actuelle
un constat au coeur des travaux du
politologue et universitaire hamadi
redissi un président de la république
quasi inexistant un parlement divisé et
un parti islamiste dont l'affluence ne
semble pas retombée autant de facteurs
qui expliquent l'échec de la révolution
de 2011 la crise du système politique
elle et elle est double elle est là à la
voie celle de la distribution des
pouvoirs aux de la répartition des
pouvoirs entre les deux branches de
l'exécutif et entre l'exécutif et le
législatif et elle est liée au mode de
scrutin le champ politique il est à la
fois mine est fermée
ils n'arrivent pas à trouver de solution
à l'intello à l'extérieur monde hors de
la légalité
donc quand vous me dites est ce qu'il y
a le risque d'implosion ou oui et je
vois mal les acteurs politiques
aujourd'hui capable de mener un grand
dialogue national sur le modèle 2013
2014 crise politique économique sociale
et aujourd'hui sanitaire la tunisie
semble être au bord de l'implosion dix
ans après la chute du président ben ali
entre crise partisane au corruption ou
encore problèmes dus au système
parlementaire qui ne permet pas les
réformes nécessaires celles qui
aspiraient tout espoir de la jeunesse
tunisienne et celle du monde arable
semble s'éloigner progressivement de ce
qui avait porté ce jeune peuple cette
jeune démocratie
un changement et un renouveau